قالت وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه ان الاحتلال
ارتكب اث عش مجزره في حق المدنيين في
القطاع راح ضحيتها
122 شهيدا
و256 جريحا خلال ال 4 ساعه الماضيه وبذلك
ترتفع حصيله الحرب منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الى اكثر من
22700 شهيد و
5866 6
جريحا ونشر المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي بغزه
تحديثا لاهم الاحصائيات المتعلقه بالحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه وقال ان الاحتلال
وخلال 992 يوما من حرب الاباده الجماعيه
ارتكب
1903 مجازر بحق المدنيين في قطاع غزه وحسب
احصائيات المكتب يصل عدد الشهداء
والمفقودين الى 29 و700
و22 شهيدا
ومفقوده منهم 100 الا طفل شهيد منذ بدء
العدوان على القطاع كما وصل عدد الشهيدات
من النساء الى 7000 شهيده وقال المكتب ان
عدد المصابين جراء العدوان الاسرائيلي وصل
الى
5866 مصابا واضاف المكتب ان جيش الاحتلال
دمر
69 حده سكنيه كليا
و290 الف وحده سكنيه بشكل جزئي منذ بدء
عدوانه على غزه وقد اخرج الاحتلال 30
مستشفى في القطاع عن الخدمه بشكل كامل الى
جانب 53 مركزا صحيا اخرجها القصف
الاسرائيلي عن الخدمه واشار المكتب الى ان
جنود الاحتلال سرقوا اموالا وذهبا من
القطاع بق 90 مليون
شيكل